talk about popular recommendation
algorithm type of algorithms well
cooperating food drinks and the nice
empirical observation about a specific
type of filtering will try to explain or
at least understand to extent in this
tester so let's just quickly recap what
I mean by recommendation system is
Gordon Thomas he just like that and then
there are few other books he is read by
mistake sometimes and then there he is
read somebody mistake something not by
mistake and I'm showing you curious why
I put the last one we can ask that to
him this is what guy has read and what
he is liked and we know that that comes
movie news also like in which market so
he's got two good things and not so few
good things and now based on this our
sort of Louie wants to figure out what
are the other books he should be well
looks like he's a nice interest match
pretty well on things that they read so
maybe he can sort of take recommendation
from guy or his history and figure out
what he should do well he looks like
from his history he's gonna miss like
this like this so what I've done here is
that for Louie I found a users with
similar preferences and then use them to
extrapolate what Louis preferences would
be on things that he is not this is
what's known as we most of us know
called user user collaborative the dress
okay now myself come in I'm here seven
foot very immature
I come in and I'm let's just write one
book with that caveat for a second I
want to read something more for the
section 3 but I like this book this book
is like these other books and since I
like this one maybe ever liked those 2
and hence maybe the recommendation
should be that hey go read one of those
two books this is called item items
cooperated with me that is I found out
things that I liked and then I found out
the items that are like those like items
and then I shall have recommended myself
business and purpose of the talk is to
try to understand this item item
collaborative filtering now of course in
practice if you look at it there's lots
of lots of details that should go beyond
just this kind of simple explanations
you're not able to talk about that
purpose of this talk and we'll think of
a generic item item style paradigm and
try to see self what we can do
what's the difference thank you so here
it's me I'm good look at items that I'm
like and this is Gordon Thomas then
we'll get all the items that look like
this one is that all the books that I
like this one well how do I figure it
out well let me look at the history of
this book in terms of users well this
book has plus one plus one here this
also has presentation here like this
this one says plus one doesn't here like
this but this is a rig-veda said it
could be the Pope guy and the other
gentleman that I do not know also really
liked you know Dilbert
right and so on the Dilbert is not very
much like Oberon Thomas mmm it's like
this this dimension this dimension is
nothing to do with these key dimensions
at all in some sense that's the whole
point
okay so this is what we're sort of
actually understand when kinds of item
item cloud considering what and why and
how that okay so this sort of and hello
this is basic model but some users about
some items and for every user I can ban
if there is the preference of user for
that item it's a plus one or minus one
and it's a sparse matrix that I know and
based on this I will figure out for all
the unknown entries what would that be
and once I know that a reasonable
prediction for that decides which items
to predict would recommend to achieve
alright so which algorithms you use I
will just explain to you two sets of
algorithms which are primarily the
nearest
Nonna's collaborative filtering
algorithm the user using an item and
there are many other algorithms for this
problem and he is just one broad
category algorithm its completion the
very long list of work as most of you
might know this topic board last five
years there's another class of
algorithms called
family of reinforcement learning style
and here a few references and the ones
that have not listed here prominently
what these try to do is try to balance
some form of explore and exploit alright
in this talk I'm going to focus on this
class of talks this demo this time of
type of algorithms in particular we were
inspired by this nice simple observation
vanilla seems in practice item items
collaborative filtering does work better
than the using question is that if so
why can we explain in some form so the
set up a simple here is a very simple
model of knowing their end users each
user has preference in terms of personal
resume that there are some number of
items that say em and then each item
will have can be determined by
references of the end users that means
that for each item I can associate a
binary string of London alternatively I
could think of items as coming from a
distribution on I think draw infinitely
many items as for this distribution in
ID manner if you have finite is set of
items you'll see sort of what happens
before what was of most of the table let
me assume that I can draw it but it's
coming from prescribed history no
exactly there is no loss of generality
any questions
each item is determined by just this
binary string it is what I did this item
is drawn from the same description from
given fixed distribution and if I find
it if I can I'm saying this is my
population alright and here's how I will
at least try to understand the
performance of algorithms I'm going to
say that my system is time clocked at
each time I'm going to choose one of
them users at random and this
recommendation question piece of how
well am i doing well I'm gonna earn a
reward if the item that I recommended to
this user actually sheerly like that I
will lose goal would be to affect me for
any time T or maximize the total amount
of reward ever
now this is very good and especially if
one is looking at this kind of objective
and ste increases one would like to see
this roughly running the world affecting
all the time
if physically is that another piece
instead of any practical system there
will not care about it but you get on to
the system and the first thing I want to
make sure that I learn your preferences
very quickly so I can start giving you
recommendations it's better than random
and one way to capture that is to try to
find out that minimize the time it takes
for me to do you meaningful recognize
and meaningful accommodation with the
recommendation is better than just more
commonly here with a look at will try to
we defined as this that is literally I'm
assuming that since I've got infinitely
many items in principle I could before
every user find out an item that he or
she likes this is the best I could do
and then look at the difference and is
there to normalize and the other one is
the cold start and is able to find out
the smallest time it takes after which
if a user is segment an item the user
writing that item is better than the
random alright and I'm following these
recommendations for users that never
repeat them
there are two ways to look at it but if
you consume the movie is unlikely that
you would like to consume the movie we
know it's debatable some movies you
might want to conduct rain if you have
purchased a computer right now we are
unlikely to buy another computer
immediately on the other hand if you if
I'm going to recommend you a restaurant
that you already like to go there is no
sort of nothing exciting about that
recommendation algorithms performance
it's really what we're going to evaluate
the performance of recommendation of
being on things that algorithm doesn't
know about users preference on and
that's why we're opposing this in a
situation where a user is on ways
recommended in unseen item and now
setting you see that as pointed out well
unless there is some structure in terms
of how users choose items or how items
that like by use it there's nothing you
can do anything better than random
formally for example if you have
distribution mu which is describing
describe five users preferences on items
and if it's uniform and no algorithm can
do better
there's no information so you want to be
both some structure structure well he is
this one experiment isn't it this
popular movie lens data set and then
took the densest
sub matrix of that movie lines data set
and then we plot it well color the black
and white scale is 275 it's quantized
plus one minus one similarity looks like
very blockage athletes seem to suggest
that maybe there are a few distinct
types of items are out there make sense
more generous way to think of this is
the distribution has some parental
intervention and classically we would
think of coming to mention notion in the
context of metric space good see a
natural variation of this for
distribution as follows so let's imagine
that these are all possible plus one
minus one about any strings now let me
take any any ball in that in please if I
increase its radius by 2 and the
probability mass of this larger ball is
no more than T to power T times division
I want to find the smallest session
and small sh t will determine the the W
dimension of you and you require that is
fine if you think of the random at the
uniform distribution the uniform
distribution is effectively NR n minus 1
as dimensions it's not signing and of
course there you're not getting any any
collaboratively and effectively the hope
is that if I have smaller dimension then
maybe I can gain some more for example
if you have few types let's say
different types and then it's this is
the whiteboard which is newest new is
the distribution on the words antennas
and about users or nope atoms I got
confused
baser I've got end users and for purpose
let's think of items is an infinite pool
of items from which I can put and each
time I put an item I'm pulling an item
from a distribution you knew is over -
we just went to power and so for example
I put an item from here
I'd say items come and let's suppose for
a second and equals to 3 then item comes
out to me a string like this minus 1
that's 1 minus 1 plus 1 this is 1 item
what this would mean is that user 1
likes it - its likes it use it
so your original question was to
understand differences between item item
collaboration versus using the
collaboration and this binding I'm just
gonna try to understand how you might
think love because the water seems where
is it you could easily put a
distribution on you roll on users yes so
this sounds asymmetric right now because
I made this infinite it's in for a
second they get finite let's think
simply in terms of finite types where a
type is one will think of a type arrays
of simplistic form this there are each
item is coming from a mixture
distribution of different mixtures and
each mixture is the data distribution at
their distribution on one of the binary
strings so in that case if I have K
types on item space lead to naturally no
more than two to power key types on user
space so that is there is a nice of
symmetry between these two problems and
the reason I'm looking at this variation
of this asymmetric goodbye phenomena is
like lighting
rock- that because look let's look at
matrix right you can think of you're
finding a way to generate this matrix in
fact right but here you are assuming
some correlation because view is not ID
across users but across items has
independently drawn from the same
distribution so there's a symmetric
assumption in terms of general name is
matrix so you could imagine so if you
start sort of thinking of that way if
you look a symmetric but if you think
about let's suppose I've got a
population of items there's no
distribution yet so ever M items now I'm
going to look at histogram of the
distribution that these items would in
in views on -
comment apart and since for the purpose
of the recommendation algorithm how do i
label the items does not matter it
effectively looks like as if sort of if
I started generating matrix by picking
columns it look like as if serve I'm
choosing to errors items uniformly pack
items at random as per this fashion this
is setting in the same order from the
users the users you don't have to label
them either it's correct you can under
similar users and they don't need to
user user Club with everything and it
would help watch performance there I
will show you here there is tiny
reference that I put down for the dealer
said he'll talk offline
that means of get to the punchline in
three minutes
okay so here's what I'm going to analyze
this per user which this shows you that
they're liking is you this is like
saying there so if I recommend it a
random user random item this is how well
I'll do now definitely I want my
algorithm to do better than this and I
start looking at my regret over time
which will happen is initially I have
not no idea
I know information about user terribly
and as well as random recommendations
but maybe after a while that I will
learn something about a system this old
start of this system maybe I will
actually do well and I will actually
have
which is very good it's exactly saying
that I'm recommending good items with
pretty high probability and then after
some time because I've got limited users
and conserves thinking of item infinite
maybe I won't get any more collaborative
game between users and after that my
regret will be the year but just scaling
it much smaller rate this is effectively
user limited now if I had is if I did
not infinite items inside of finite
items we all have to stop somebody
everybody so this is the style of result
from would expect and first question is
that how well if cold start with no
under these assumptions the cold start
skills as this well this is the constant
that's coming from the random fraction
of items are light and depends only on
dimension and nothing else so it's a
good news because it doesn't depend on
for example number of users this is the
best one can hope for but ideally one
would hope that if I'm a user I think of
the first slide example it that I showed
you I am a user how long does it take me
to get a first good recommendation well
it's news affection then I takes one
over an infraction user head of the
first look at maybe after that the best
algorithm is actually starting Unicode
recommendation after that should be true
dusty these the dimension of the
distribution dimension comes into play
if smaller it's that large it gets worse
is when expect and finally the time till
which you can get nice severe regret
depends on the number of users and after
that your slope is scaling down like
this so more number of users you have
better you should stop here an algorithm
high-level it looks something like this
but look that's just sufficient if I
Teresa saying what I can do it is the
cost of exploration I can spread over
users every user while he or she is
coming in the system so very small
amount of time per user that they will
spend to actually explore selectively
and after that they will get benefit
under than anything the user user is
what you do you have to explore all
users and when you explore all users
each user has to pay cost of their own
exploration so that means it will take
longer for them to start getting good
recommendation today is the fundamental
is symmetry in the problem itself and
that's why
item item I prefer yeah
this there's no phenomenal reason I can
tell you headed this way
looks like the racer of one would
imagine I don't have any phenomenal
lower bound but I would believe the
Redis the way we looked at the problem
you see similar experience showing up in
the Bandit